dauern aber es gibt einen lichtblick und
das ist die hilfsbereitschaft die
solidarität der menschen und die ist
riesig wir wollen heute darauf schauen
wie können wir helfen unsere
spendengelder in den hochwasser
katastrophengebieten was wird benötigt
wie kommt die hilfe dort an wie wird
dafür gesorgt dass die gelder die
spendengelder effizient eingesetzt
werden und dass eben auch kein
schindluder damit getrieben wird
wir wollen außerdem wissen wie lange
wird der wiederaufbau dauern was wird da
alles benötigt wo kommt worauf kommt es
dabei an
und wir können sprechen wollen sprechen
mit zwei menschen die sich sehr sehr gut
damit auskennen die viel erfahrung haben
auch schon 2013 als es auch eine
hochwasserkatastrophe gab wir reden
heute zum einen mit dominik man vom
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
sie sind ja nicht nur jetzt aktiv
sondern waren auch 2013 bei der letzten
großen flut hochwasserkatastrophe aktiv
insofern können sie uns viel dazu sagen
und wir reden auch mit jürgen opitz er
ist bürgermeister von heidenau an der
elbe in sachsen das 2013 schwer
getroffen wurde vom elbe hochwasser
zerstört wurde und er kann uns
ausführlich berichten wie leicht das
wort wiederaufbau sich aussprechen lässt
aber wie gewaltig dann die aufgaben doch
sind größe der heidener schön dass sie
mit der weise und herr opitz
die beiden werden sicherlich auch ihre
fragen ausführlich beantworten können
also einfach her damit wir werden dann
im laufe des livestreams die fragen
stellen und beantworten zunächst aber
blicken wir ganz aktuell nach stolberg
bei aachen
dieser ort ist auch vom hochwasser jetzt
vor knapp drei wochen schwer getroffen
worden heute waren dort zu gast zu
besuch die beiden kanzlerkandidaten
armin laschet und olaf scholz der cdu
ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen und der spd
bundesfinanzminister und was sie dort
gesehen haben was sie dort gesagt haben
auch zum thema wiederaufbau
das wollen wir jetzt sehen
stolberg bei aachen auch hier hat die
flut gewütet zwei kanzler kandidaten
inspizieren gemeinsam die schäden beiden
ist klar der klimawandel wird hier
sichtbar und steht ganz oben auf der
aufgabenliste kommender regierungen dass
wir klima anpassungsmaßnahmen in großem
umfang brauchen und auch das wird viel
veränderung bedeuten und auch viele
milliarden kosten das land auf den
stattfindenden klimawandel vorzubereiten
und ihn dann zu bekämpfen
olaf scholz geht noch weiter der
klimawandel eine jahrhundertaufgabe
was der staat zusätzlich tun muss das
kann und soll er tun und deshalb ist der
bundeshaushalt auch in der finanzplanung
der nächsten jahre
ausgestattet mit dem höchsten
investitions etat den der bund jemals
hatte ein eigenes klimaschutz
ministerium sprechen beide nicht an
einig sind sich die konkurrenten bei
milliardenschweren wiederaufbau v ist
dann eine länder bund übergreifende
parteiübergreifende initiative in dieser
größten unwetterkatastrophe die wir ja
seit mindestens 100 jahren in dieser
region erlebt haben wir werden das
besprechen auch in gut vorbereiten für
die konferenz der ministerpräsidentinnen
und ministerpräsidenten zusammen mit der
bundesregierung und dann auch den
notwendigen schritt gehen der dann in
einer gesetzgebung bestehen wird die das
für die nächsten jahre sichert
mindestens sechs milliarden würden für
den wiederaufbau gebraucht der fonds
soll schnellstens kommen und bleiben
unabhängig davon wer im september
gewinnt
oder falls hatte ihn stolper gesagt der
wiederaufbau werde milliarden
verschlingen gleichzeitig versichert er
das geld stehe von bund und ländern
bereit jetzt wollen wir eben mit unseren
gästen darüber sprechen wie
spendengelder helfen können und wieder
wiederaufbau aussieht mit dominik man
vom aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe und
dem bürgermeister aus heidenau jürgen
opitz hermann wie viel geld müssen wir
jetzt einfach mal frage wir machen das
ja auch im zdf spenden sie geld
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe jetzt
verraten sie doch mal wie viel geld ist
denn bis zum heutigen tag schon
zusammengekommen
die spendenbereitschaft ist wirklich
überwältigend und die bevor die zahlen
nennen möchte ich erstmal den
spenderinnen und spendern den
zuschauerin des zdf nicht alleine aber
ganz viel davon haben gespendet ganz
ganz herzlich sage sind über 400.000
spenden und die unglaubliche
spendensumme von 71,6 millionen sind bis
heute nachmittag eingegangen also
wirklich eine überwältigende
spendenbereitschaft wir uns nur bedanken
können und die wir mit sicherheit nach
besten wissen und gewissen für die
betroffenen mit den hochwassergebieten
einsetzen da müssen sie das mal einen
ordnen
klingt für mich jetzt unwahrscheinlich
viel aber ist das jetzt ein tropfen auf
den heißen stein oder ist das etwas was
so bei anderen katastrophen noch nicht
gegeben hat katastrophen miteinander zu
vergleichen um die spendenbereitschaft
zu vergleichen ist immer sehr schwierig
weil keine katastrophe ist wie die
andere
ich bin jetzt seit rund 17 jahren in
verschiedenen funktionen im mitnehmen
bereich tätig und habe so was wie gesagt
noch nicht erlebt 2004 tsunami war
insgesamt waren es 550 millionen
privatspenden in deutschland das kann
man überhaupt nicht vergleichen war eine
ganz andere katastrophe die zeit war
eine ganz andere
auch die möglichkeiten spenden
einzuwerben waren andere aber in den
letzten 10 jahren 15 jahren sogar eine
die legalität noch nicht erlebt insofern
deckt sich das was wir ja auch immer
wieder in berichten hören dass die
menschen vor ort in den
katastrophengebieten ja einerseits
tränen in den augen haben über das was
verloren gegangen ist aber eben auch
sozusagen freudentränen über diese
hilfsbereitschaft jetzt erklären sie
einfach mal hilfsbereitschaft da gibt es
ja auch viele haben auch schon beiträge
gehabt die sagen ich habe noch einen
kinderwagen
übrig ich kann noch einen kühlschrank
spenden und so weiter warum sind aber
jetzt gelder spendengelder besser so zu
sagen was die hilfe angehen
es hat mehrere ebenen zum einen und das
ist das was sich das aktions wird bzw
die organisation dem aktions bildet sich
zusammengeschlossen haben zur caritas
international deutsches rotes kreuz
diakonie katastrophenhilfe und unicef
deutschland gehe jetzt aber in
katastrophengebieten nicht tätig sind
die keine projekte da haben sie
schreiben sich egal ob eine bayer
nationalen katastrophe aller
internationalen katastrophe immer auf
die fahnen bedarfsgerecht den
betroffenen an bedarf zu helfen zu
schauen was brauchen die am dringendsten
und was die menschen am nötigsten
brauchen das wissen sie eigentlich
selbst am besten
und von da ist jetzt auch die ersten
maßnahmen sind bargeldauszahlung in
überschaubaren größenordnung da geht es
nicht um zehntausende euro 500 euro 1000
euro 1500 euro und die leute können dann
genau dass sich dafür anschaffen sich
das dafür kaufen was sie am dringendsten
brauchen der eine braucht jetzt sofort
vielleicht ein neues so für eine neue
waschmaschine der andere braucht
dringend bekleidung oder will weil er
keine möglichkeit habe unterzukommen
zwei tage in der fraktion haben
das ist der eine punkt weiß
bedarfsorientierter ist und der andere
punkt ist wir haben auch ganz viele beim
aktionsbündnis anfragen bekommen ich
habe hier gerade ein ganz neues sofa das
will ich gerne den betroffenen schenken
kann also die hilfsbereitschaft auch in
diesem bereich ist wahnsinnig groß aber
ist eine logistik aufzubauen können sie
bitte das sofa in deggendorf oder in
hamburg abholen das ist einfach nicht
möglich und würde die kapazitäten
komplett springen es ist einfach nicht
möglich
und aus diesem grund auch wenn es noch
so gut gemeint ist nachvollziehbar ist
es mag vielleicht mal in einigen wochen
monaten ein gebrauchtes sofern notwendig
seien aber jetzt im moment so schnöde
das klingt ist geld die beste hilfe die
man momentan leisten kann und sie sagen
dass die leute wissen es am besten was
sie selbst haben wollen was sie brauchen
aber noch vielleicht was sie haben
wollen vielleicht muss das sofa anders
sein und insofern ist das gespendete
sofa vielleicht eben auch gar nicht so
perfekt wir können ja jetzt einfach mal
mit jemandem reden der das vor vielen
jahren 2013 alles miterlebt hat und
einfach mal nach ihren erfahrungen und
fragen 2013 wurde heidenau
das ist so zwischen
ja südlich von dresden zwischen pillnitz
und pirna von der elbe zerstört die das
hochwasser hat eben vieles zerstört wir
haben einige bilder vorbereitet und sehr
opel als bürgermeister können vielleicht
diese bilder auch ein bisschen
kommentieren damit wir erstmal überhaupt
erfahren
die war das 2013 was sie da sozusagen
überrollt hat vielleicht können wir die
bilder einfach mal sehen und sie
beschreiben das mal so das klappt
technisch nicht aber trotzdem
wir können es uns ungefähr vorstellen
ich habe sehr viele bilder mir angesehen
also straßen komplett überschwemmt sind
noch die verkehrsschilder kamen oben
raus schulen abgesoffenen häuser etc
wie ist das bei ihnen gewesen und wie
haben sie das eben auch erlebt mit der
spendenbereitschaft das hochwasser 2002
kam quasi mit ansage
das war das hochwasser von der elbe wir
haben die möglichkeit die pegelstände
mit einem vorlauf von drei vier tagen
uns anzuschauen wir haben ein neues
warnsystem 2013 bereits gehabt so dass
in der tat mit dem anstieg der elbe sich
die pegel lagen vor
im vorfeld der stadt eingestellt haben
und da kam eben irgendwann der zeitpunkt
wo das wasser über diese gerne weiter
über einen bahndamm rüber gelaufen ist
und dann breitete sich das wasser
entsprechend in großen teilen unserer
stadt aus und vor dem hintergrund und
mit den erfahrungen eines wesentlich
schlimmeren hochwasser 2002 haben sowohl
die einwohner ganz anders reagieren
können als auch die stadt als so viel
polizei dass das katastrophen team hat
anders reagieren können und vor dem
hintergrund sind die beiden ereignisse
jetzt im jahr 2021 und 2013
eigentlich kaum vergleichbar aber herr
opitz wir haben ja gerade darüber
gesprochen
die leute wollen helfen aber hermann hat
gerade deutlich gemacht es ist ein
problem wenn jetzt jeder den kinderwagen
spendet und den kühlschrank
wie haben sie das denn erlebt oder was
sind beispiele ihre erfahrungen damit
wenn man sagt auf der einen seite
sachspenden gut gemeint und auf der
anderen seite habe ich schon oft gehört
dass helfer sagen lieber geld spenden
lieber geld spenden weil das flexibler
einsetzbar ist ja das kann ich nur
bestätigen
der aufwand sachspenden zu sammeln zu
sortieren herauszugehen und vor allen
dingen die reste zu entsorgen
der ist riesengroß und verbindet so
viele freiwillige kräfte die an anderer
stelle wesentlich sinnvoller einsetzbar
sind
außerdem ist es so wie sie sagen die
leute möchten gerne selber entscheiden
ob sie sich eine jacke kaufen eine rose
oder eben eine maschine die sie dringend
brauchen um ihr haus wieder in ordnung
zu bringen und vor dem hintergrund kann
ich das nur bestätigen
geldspenden sind das allerbeste und viel
schneller diese geldspenden zur
auszahlung kommen und so effektiver
helfen diese also sachspenden wenn sie
dann am ende rumstehen und auch noch
abtransportiert werden müssen dann
können sie am ende hermann ja vielleicht
noch das problem sein dann muss man sich
nicht nur um das abtransportieren von
schlamm und trümmern und kaputten
baumstämmen kümmern sondern am ende
stehen dann da weiß ich noch drei
kühlschränke und waschmaschinen ist das
tatsächlich so ein bisschen gut gemeint
aber verursacht dann vielleicht sogar
ein problem das kann dazu führen wenn
also die die sachspenden die wirklich
wie sie auch sagen gut gemeint sind aber
zu viel werden dann ja dann ist das was
jetzt schon in großen mengen auf die
mülldeponie gebracht werden musste weil
es vom hochwasser zerstört wurde
letztendlich steht es dann darum und
wirklich gebraucht weil er wird
neugeräte da sind oder teilweise alte
geräte sie passen nicht in die wohnung
in die neue gibt unterschiedliche gründe
warum es dann einfach nicht passt und da
ist dann unter umständen das eine gute
hilfe eine gut gemeinte hilfe aber
vielleicht nicht die allerbeste
jetzt ist es so heute sagen die
politiker europas die landeschefs es
wird
kroatisch geholfen manche gelder sind
auch schon geflossen haben wir eben im
beitrag gehört wie war das denn damals
bei ihnen in sachsen heidenau südlich
von dresden
da hat die landesregierung ja auch
gesagt wir helfen kann das funktioniert
gab es dann auch so ein bisschen wie der
mann sagte schnell wenig geld muss jetzt
nicht große summe seien aber dass die
leute wieder flüssig wurden wie ist das
denn bei ihnen gewesen
also es gar unmittelbaren noch wäre die
elbe auf den straßen und teilweise in
den kellern oder erst geschossen stand
gab es schon die erste soforthilfe die
wurde über die gemeinden ausgezahlt und
es hat jeder erwachsene sofort 400 euro
gefordert
in einer familie maximal 2000 euro und
diese sofort hilfe die es sehr schnell
und sehr unbürokratisch geflossen so
dass sich die leute versorgen konnten
und essen kaufen konnten
wir haben dann bemüht einen zentralen
ort wo essen gekocht werden konnte und
ausgegeben werk werden konnte zu
installieren
aber diese hilfe die bei einer tat sehr
unbürokratisch und es folgten dann noch
weitere gelder zum beispiel also auch
spenden von der sächsischen zeitung über
das programm aktion lichtblick sind noch
mal sehr viele gelder gekommen die
diakonie hat sich mit vielen
zusammengetan und hat spenden gesammelt
und diese spenden dann auch verteilt und
das zog sich dann über mehrere wochen im
nachgang hin und lassen sie mich das
noch sagen also ich brauche keine neue
couch wenn mein haus schon wieder zwei
von wasser ist aber ich definitiv noch
ein halbes jahr die tochter laufen
lassen muss dann mit die wände wieder
trocken werden und wieviel fußböden auch
das sind zeitläufe jemand einfach
einkalkulieren muss muss und da brauchen
leute eine zusätzliche belastung durch
neues hab und gut definitiv nicht also
sie
reden und erklären das einfach mal aus
der praxis dass man sich das einfach mal
vorstellen muss wenn jetzt heute
jemanden sofa spendet für jemanden im
aartal ja das kann eben überhaupt nicht
hilfreich sein wie sie gerade sagen wenn
erstmal über monate die wände getrocknet
werden müssen dann braucht man das sofa
vielleicht im januar
und solange kann man es auch nicht
irgendwo herumstehen lassen und dann
hilft es nicht also das sind die ganz
praktischen erfahrungen hermann jetzt
haben sie gesagt über 70 also 71 16
millionen euro an spendengelder
jetzt kommt das interessante aber wie
kommen die denn jetzt genau zu den
menschen also wenn ich jetzt 100 euro an
das aktionsbündnis spende dann möchte
ich ja eigentlich auch ganz gerne wissen
wie kommt das denn nun an wie gericht
die frau müller in sozusagen schuld oder
der herr schmitz in bad
neuenahr-ahrweiler jetzt mein geld und
kann wirklich davon profitieren also
alles schmeckt die aktion zumindest
eingehen von der ein euro spende bis zu
der ein millionen spende die wir
wirklich in diesem in dieser range auch
bekommen haben werden auf die drei
mitgliedsorganisationen die tätig sind
verteilt so caritas international
diakonie katastrophenhilfe ein deutsches
rotes kreuz und die wiederum
organisieren die hilfe und setzten die
maßnahmen über ihre lokalen strukturen
um und das große glück ist in dem fall
das ist einfach die strukturen der
operation so sind das in der kleinsten
ort in der ganzen stadt gibt eine
caritas aktion einen kreisverein vom
deutschen roten kreuz oder eine
diakoniestation und genau das sind die
anlaufstellen wo die betroffenen sich
hinwenden können und sollen
das in den ersten tagen gab es mobile
teams von der caritas vom deutschen
roten kreuz und von der diakonie die
eben zu den leuten gegangen sind damit
beschäftigt war das was aus ihren
häusern zu bekommen aber was können wir
tun was braucht er jetzt als erstes
haben da schon bargeld hilfen ganz
unbürokratisch ausgezahlt und jetzt wo
das ganze sich etwas etwas schon ins
positive entwickelt hat sollen die leute
zu diesen lokalen stationen gehen und da
kann bargeld hilfen ausgezahlt werden
trockner geräte was herr opitz gerade
ansprache ist ganz ganz wichtig
trockengeräte wetter ausgegeben das sind
die allerersten kleinen maßnahmen also
es ist jetzt nicht so dass jetzt sage
ich mal herr dominik mann aus frankfurt
anreist und sich das erstmal alles
anguckt sondern die leute die vor ort
genau wissen was man in bad neuenahr
braucht den arbeiter auf der anderen
heute vielleicht nicht hat und so weiter
weil sie dort leben die entscheiden wo
wird die hilfe wird das geld am besten
eingesetzt also insofern diejenigen die
es am besten wissen wie kann man denn
jetzt aber irgendwie verhindern dass
jetzt damit schindluder betrieben wird
also der eine ist einmal herr müller
zweimal die hilfe bekommt die frau
schmitz geht leer aus das möchte ich der
100 euro spendet ja nicht wie vermeiden
sie das denn jetzt also in den ersten in
den ersten tagen jetzt in den ersten
wochen wird auch bei den ersten paar
helfen wird das so sein dann müssen die
betroffenen das geld erhalten das ist
beispielsweise bis zu 1500 euro pro
familie pro haus stand müssen für
unterschreiben dass sie sonst nie
irgendetwas beantragt haben nichts
bekommen haben und betroffene sind dass
es bei den ersten ball auszahlung mit
dem haushalt so genannte haushaltshilfe
und geht dann gibt es auch schon eine
bedürftigkeitsprüfung in den erste
ausfallen wird das muss unbürokratisch
sein man kann es überhaupt auch gar
nicht nachweisen
im zweiten schritt dann wird natürlich
geschaut ist die bedürftigkeit da und
auch um auch zu vermeiden dass leute
mehrfach beantragen oder auch nicht
betroffene beantragen
und es ist auch jetzt schon mit der
erfahrung von 20 13 die das phoenix die
phoenix datenbank aufgebaut wurde damals
vom deutschen roten kreuz von sachsens
vom landesverband aufgebaut die
datenbank wo jede ausgezahlte und
erfolgte hilfe erfasst wird von allen
organisationen die in der katastrophe in
dem katastrophengebiet tätig sind und
dann fliegen alle ein die das wollen und
können und dadurch kann dann wenn es um
vor allem größere summen auch geht bei
unterstützungen vom wiederaufbau von
wohnraum beispielsweise wo dann eben
nicht mehr 15 euro sondern auch mal
15.000 euro eventuell gezahlt werden
können dass das eben dort festgehalten
wird um dann eben eventuell schindluder
oder auch betrugs zu vermeiden
das ist ja so ein bisschen die crux war
möchte ja natürlich so schnell wie
möglich helfen auch ich möchte wenn ich
100 euro spende dass das geld so schnell
wie möglich helfen helfen kann den
menschen zugute kommt auf der anderen
seite muss ein bisschen bürokratie ein
bisschen papierkram 1
eingepflegt werden sozusagen damit es
doch sozusagen korrekt ablaufen
das kommt auch an um welche hilfe es
geht um die ganz schnelle hilfe also
jetzt sich neue kleidung zu kaufen wenn
man sich kaufen kann
also wird diese ersten tage erst in zwei
drei wochen um ich möchte sagen das
überleben zu sichern aber um ein
einigermaßen und geordnetes leben wie es
wie es möglich ist ebenso ermöglichen
das läuft unbürokratisch damit vertraut
man auf die versicherung der betroffenen
ausgezahlt bekommen haben
da gibt es keine andere möglichkeit weil
eben nicht nur die spender das wollen
wir auch die stationen wollen den
menschen ja schnellstmöglich helfen
richtig brauchen die hilfe sofort bei
allen anderen dingen muss man ein stück
wird um verständnis bitten dass gewisse
bürokratische schritte notwendig sind um
dann eben auch dem spender wunsch dass
wir die betroffenen und die wirklich es
nötig haben
das denen geholfen wird und nicht dem
die es eigentlich nicht nötig haben weil
sie eine versicherung haben oder andere
dinge haben und wir haben schon eine
trocknung brauchen nicht noch zwei
andere trockner die sie dann auf dem
schwarzmarkt eventuell verkaufen
das kommt bisher überhaupt nicht vor
aber um dieses auch mit zu verhindern
ist eine gewisse kontrolle möchte nicht
sagen oder gewisse bürokratie einfach
notwendig man kann sich das ja
eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen dass da
bedruckt wird
vielleicht doppelt kassiert wird aber
man hat ja ebenso gewisse erfahrungen
werden wir jetzt zum beispiel ja auch
gehört dass da ich sag mal verrückte
durch die gegend fahren und
falschmeldungen verbreiten wo man sich
sozusagen an den kopf fasst und sagt
haben die leute die so viel schlimmes
erlebt haben nichts besseres als das
auch noch zu erleben
aber sie haben ja auch 2013 einige
erfahrungen gemacht dass man eben ein
bisschen auch in einem
katastrophengebiet auf der hut sein muss
und manche die situation der betroffenen
schamlos ausnutzen richtig das ist
wichtig also ich kann das nur bestätigen
dass der mann gesagt hat als erstes und
novartis
dann darf diese phoenix datenbank und
danach eben auch noch die erklärung wo
leute dargelegt haben welche gelder sie
erhalten haben und viele haben ja in den
ersten tagen gar nicht gewusst was sie
alles bekommen können und haben das dann
noch teilweise selber zurückgezahlt wenn
sie gemerkt haben
sie haben von anderer seite größte
großzügigere hilfe bekommen
das kann ich nur bestätigen das war wir
uns auch so und die gefahr besteht
natürlich dass ich gewisse
geschäftemacher unter die bartlosen
mischen und spezielle trockenverfahren
für gebäude zb anbieten dort sich
verträge unterzeichnen lasten für eine
trockenlegung der taurus für eine
schnelle wiederherstellung von fenstern
und türen und bis dahin dass man sich
ein individuelles
hochwasserschutzkonzept für sein
grundstück hat andrehen lassen und all
diese dinge ganz schlimm aber die sind
auch passiert und es war immer gut wenn
leute aus unserer gemeinde verwaltung
und auch von den hilfsdiensten unterwegs
waren mit den leuten gesprochen haben
und dann einfach gesagt haben seid
vorsichtig und der streif nichts
das müssen wir erst einmal nachprüfen ob
das tatsächlich funktioniert und ob das
am ende auch bekommt aber das ist die
große gefahr dass die not und die
kopflosigkeit der branchengeschichte
jedoch wer fahren muss ausgenutzt wird
ja also der bild sagte eben ein bisschen
der wurm funktioniert nicht ganz so
erobert hat gesagt es wird so ein
bisschen das dann ausgenutzt und der
eine oder andere versucht geschäfte mit
zu machen also ist es so dass man schon
ein bisschen auf der hut sein muss also
auch die organisationen die
verantwortung tragen
es kommen jetzt hier so einige fragen
die sie hat man einfach mal beantworten
können monika störer schreibt über
facebook weil sie ja gerade sagten 1500
euro das ist sozusagen die schnelle
hilfe dass die menschen flüssig sind
sich kleidung kaufen können was gerade
je nach demnach fall am notwendigsten
ist der schreibt sie drei fragezeichen
wenn man vor dem nichts steht also sie
vermutet jetzt wenn das alles ist kann
man mit 1500 euro nicht viel machen aber
vielleicht erklären sie das nochmal klar
wenn jemand sein ganzes haus einfach
nicht mehr bewohnbar ist dann hilfen
1500 euro nichts das ist völlig klar
aber für den ersten schritt um einfach
mal die nächsten tage zu überstehen um
sich fit wie sie auch gesagt und
kleidung zu kaufen
weg ist nicht nichts mehr habe außer der
gern sich am leib getragen habe dann ist
das für die gesamte zone natürlich ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein aber man
kann jetzt nicht einfach losziehen und
sagen okay man hat sein haus flog und
bekommt jetzt 102 300.000 den wert des
hauses sozusagen direkt ausgezahlt das
ist einfach nicht möglich dazu ist
einfach diese situation noch in
anführungszeichen zu unübersichtlich ich
kann die die die frage verstehen ich
vielleicht noch ein wort was herr opitz
auch sagte aufpassen an wen man geräte
falsche berater also ich weiß es ist von
den drei stationen die tätig sind die
haben ihre flut koordinatoren im gebiet
die kennen sich aus mit überschwemmungen
seit 20 13 20 2 aber auch international
sind internationalen weltweit aktiv und
erfahren und die die lokalen strukturen
dienen auch dazu da waren berät wenn man
sagt auf mich ist niemand zugekommen als
betroffener
ich habe das angebot für den
wiederaufbau viel getrunken des hauses
taugt das was taugt das nicht genau dazu
wird es auch ein ganz großer teil der
hilfe sein die leute zu beraten ist das
was jetzt vor habt richtig wie könnt ihr
das formular am besten auch sein wo
könnte noch andere hilfen vom staat von
der versicherung beantragen und eben
auch auf die expertise der international
erfahrene experten für solche
katastrophen zurückgreifen zu können zu
sagen was ist jetzt genau wichtig weil
wir haben in deutschland diese erfahrung
in heidenau in anderen gebieten aus 20
22 13 jahren aber jede katastrophe ist
anders und da braucht man eben diese
experten die dann genau sagen können was
jetzt am besten
der erste und der zweite der dritte
schritt ist was macht man insofern eine
antwort wir haben glaube ich schon so
ein bisschen die antwort gegeben an
ismael 04 straff fragt über youtube was
macht man bei betrug an diesen fluthilfe
hier ist ja auch bei den corona hilfen
der fall war
hat man denn da überhaupt ein konzept
ich frage sie jetzt einfach mal euro pet
sie haben mir erzählt dass ihr da auch
erfahrungen hatten und wenn ich das
richtig verteilt also sogar auch geld
zurückgefordert haben nicht wie würden
sie das beschreiben
ja die fälle sind natürlich sehr
individuell und wir versuchen die geduld
der menschen wieder stark geschädigt
worden sind doch schon noch ein bisschen
auszureizen
ich kenne den umstand dass
wo einst das wasser aber auch stand die
leute fünfmal am tag nach der feuerwehr
gerufen haben
dann wird der keller ausgepumpt wird in
so einer situation kann man auch den
leuten punkten verkaufen
mit ihren sie dann ihren keller
auspumpen man muss den leuten einfach
sagen so sehr wie ihr jetzt gestresst
sein und so sehr wir versucht eure
situation objektiv einzuschätzen lasst
euch einfach sagen das ist momentan für
dieses geschäfts oder für diesen vertrag
noch nicht der richtige zeitpunkt und
man muss sagen wir bleiben für euch die
die experten wie bleiben bei euch und
die sind nicht mit dem wasser sofort
wieder weg sondern wenn das wasser weg
ist fängt die arbeit erst richtig an
und ich glaube dieses
vertrauensverhältnis das muss man
aufbauen wohl wissend und da kann ich
auch ein liedchen von singen und der
hand sicherlich auch wir haben es ja
auch nicht besuchen kann man live
gesehen dass die leute natürlich
wahnsinnig und dünnhäutig sind und jetzt
schon wissen wollen
zum beispiel wie ihr haus wieder
komplett für ein paar hunderttausend
euro wieder aufgebaut werden können wenn
sie sagen wir haben jetzt gerade alles
abbezahlt und wir haben sind gerade
schaut mich mit dem haus und hier
erzählt uns das leben geht weiter
woher soll ich denn die die paar
hunderttausend euro nehmen die ich jetzt
gerade brauche aber wenn man den leuten
sagt ja schaut euch durch das haus erst
mal an ob es tatsächlich an der stelle
auch wieder hergerichtet werden kann
also wir kennen das von 2002 in
weesenstein wo also dort die einige
häuser abrasiert habe genauso wie das
auch immer teil war mit den leuten
konnte man über das thema
wohnungseinrichtung 14 tage lang
überhaupt nicht reden das kommt ja auch
noch hinzu dass die fälle ganz
individuell sind der eine hat ist auch
mein onkel wohnt in bonn
direkt am rhein da kennt man das was man
hochwasser hat im keller der räumt man
das wetter ist man fast routiniert aber
wenn man von jetzt auf gleich in der
region wo ist
ein hochwasser keine flutwellen gegeben
hat das haus wie in schuld zb sind jetzt
sich häuser weg rasiert worden wie sie
sagen herr opels dann glaube ich muss
man erstmal sacken lassen und braucht
daneben auch die gute beratung da haben
ja nicht nur die piraten hand als es
auch eine ganz wesentlicher punkt der
arbeit der aus aktionen vor ort ist bei
kindern aber auch bei den erwachsenen
ist die psychosoziale betreuung
hinterher weil in den ersten tagen steht
man wahrscheinlich so unter strom ich
habe es selber zum glück nicht erlebt
aber ich kann mir das vorstellen den
schilderungen von vor die ich gehört
habe entnehme ich dass man sterben kann
noch gar nicht wirklich fassen was ist
hier eigentlich und erst wenn das was
angesagt ist das haus ist weg oder ich
weiß nicht wann ich hier jemals wieder
einzigen kann ob ich jemals wieder an
dieser stelle bereits grad sagte
überhaupt leben kann ob ich meine heimat
vielleicht verlassen muss weil die
gefahr zu groß ist das dann wirklich die
die psychosoziale betreuung die
nachsorge die trauerbewältigung und so
wirklich so auf den punkt zu bringen ist
eine ganz ganz wichtige aufgabe und den
menschen auch da den halb zu geben dass
ihr den lebens wo die perspektiven nicht
verlieren weil auf ihrer objekte was
nutzt ist jemanden der hat jetzt gerade
sein häuschen abbezahlt oder gerade ein
riesen kredit aufgenommen junge familie
sie stehen vor dem nichts zu wissen
nicht wie sie den nächsten monat
irgendwie vielleicht überleben sollen
unter denken wie soll das leben
weitergehen
also diese sorgen die die menschen haben
die muss man sehr sehr ernst nehmen
man muss für sie da sein und nicht nur
mit geld sondern auch wirklich auf einer
seelischen ebene es mal so auszudrücken
ihnen versuchen halt zu geben nicht
natürlich den freundeskreis und bei
kindern beispielsweise schauen wir in
die organisation
das kinderprogramm angeboten werden weil
die haben traumatische erlebnisse gehabt
wurden nacht aus dem schlaf gerissen und
sehen eine acht meter wasserwand vor
sich das kann man sich gar nicht
vorstellen was ist bei kindern fällt
auch für ängste hervorruft und einfach
denen gehts auch viele sommerferien
denen so ein bisschen zumindest
versuchen ein stück weit alltag zurück
zu geben
ob das jetzt noch kleines fußballturnier
ist oder eine andere
freizeitbeschäftigung um einfach da so
kleine inseln eines vermeintlich
normalen lebens zu schaffen also geld
ist nicht alles aber auch da kann man
geld braucht man auch geld da kann immer
auch geld helfen jetzt kommt von ismael
noch mal eine frage herr man wie viel
geld ist denn bei ihnen
bisher zusammengekommen das haben wir
jetzt gesagt ganz aktuell der stand über
71 millionen euro
und er fragt wie viel ist denn davon
bisher bei den menschen angekommen kann
man das jetzt sagen ich habe deutlich
gemacht das sind ja gewisse prozesse man
kann ja nicht sagen von den 71 millionen
haben wir schon 69 sofort ausgezahlt
wenn wir gerade verstanden dass das
jagen nach gewissen kriterien ja auch
geht das kann man zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
noch knapp drei wochen nicht sagen wie
viel von den 170 millionen die auch
nicht auf einmal da waren
ausgezahlt wurden die option haben
sofort mehrere millionen soforthilfe
bereitgestellt aus ich möchte seine
rücklagen überaus einfach den mitteln
die sie haben die natürlich jetzt von
den spenden sozusagen umgesetzt werden
das lässt sich einfach nicht sagen und
dies ist auch es wäre auch falsch wenn
wir jetzt schon einen großteil
ausgegeben hätten weil die die hilfe die
kommen wird das ist die die fed sehr
viel geld kosten wird und von daher ist
die ersten tage verbrauchen in
anführungszeichen zur gesamtbetrachtung
zum gesamtaufwand nicht am wenigsten
aber sehr wenig geld im verhältnis und
es wird bestätigen können die
wiederaufbaumaßnahmen die ziehen sich
nicht über die wochen und monaten werden
sich über jahre hinziehen
ja da kommen wir zu dem thema greifen
das auf wiederaufbau
sie haben ja beide deutlich gemacht man
muss den betroffenen die ihr haus
verloren haben das auto ist weggespült
etc
auch helfen anträge zu stellen damit
sich auf einmal führen und ohren öffnen
damit man ja vielleicht auch tipps
bekommt wo kann man noch hilfe bekommen
aber wie ist das denn für sie herr opitz
als kommune gewesen
heidenau ist ja nun ziemlich klein
16.000 einwohner ungefähr
und sie sind überrollt worden und haben
einen kompletten ort neu aufbauen müssen
wie ist das denn für sie als
bürgermeister für die kommune gewesen
anträge zu stellen auf einmal eine
solche mammutaufgabe zu stellen ja und
krieg sich anders wir waren am anfang
auch sehr stark seit ich kopflos weil
das thema wie geht es mit schule weiter
wie geht es mit kinderbetreuung weiter
aber auch wie geht es mit der
städtischen infrastruktur weiter es ist
schon erstmal schön werden nach einer
woche der strom wieder zugeschaltet wird
es ist schön wenn die gasleitung
gemeldet sind dass die frei von wasser
sind und eben auch wieder quasi ans netz
gehen können wenn abwasser wieder wie
ist denn sauberes trinkwasser aus dem
hahn kommt das ist natürlich alles die
warmen bedingungen jeden kommunen
möglichst schnell erledigen müssen und
herbeischaffen müssen weil auch diese
sind wiederum voraussetzung dafür dass
in den individuellen bereichen ob das
jetzt im eigentum von wohnungen also den
einfamilienhäusern vorwärts geht aber
eben auch in den mehrfamilienhäusern das
sozusagen dort das ganze leben wieder
wasserversorgung angeht
gesichert ist denn man kann nicht ewig
aus wasserflaschen leben und seinen
ganzen wasserverbrauch über anderthalb
liter pet flaschen regen sondern man
wartet dann schon das wasser wieder aus
der puste kommen dass eine waschmaschine
wenn man sie dann wieder hat auch
funktioniert das sind all die dinge die
bleiben den kommunen übrig und da kann
ich ihnen sagen dass wir in 2013 hatten
wir etwa 14 tage zeit die schadens
erfassung durchzuführen im bereich der
öffentlichen infrastruktur und wir waren
damals der meinung wir haben gut
aufgerundet bei der einschätzung der
schadenshöhen aber das leben und das
leben muss ich ihn auch sagen das ist
illusion ihren das hochwasser 2013 und
wir haben 2020 die letzten hochwasser
schadensbeseitigung maßnahmen
abgerechnet also das dauert schon einige
zeit ist sozusagen tatsächlich diese
schäden beseitigt worden sind und dann
natürlich der fall die demokratie wenn
es darum geht diese hundertprozentige
förderung wie wir seinerzeit vom fall
schafft bekommen haben dann natürlich
auch auf heller und pfennig abzuweichen
also das ist sozusagen das war es nach
dem akuten katastrophenfall passiert und
ich glaube auch das muss man den leuten
sagen
es wird vieles wieder so sein wie es
vorher war
aber es wird jahre dauern bis man wieder
alle annehmlichkeiten wie man vorher in
seinem ort vorgefundenen hat auch wieder
so vorfinden wird und damit müssen leute
klar kommen und viele entscheiden sich
dann und sagen nee dort möchten wir
nicht wieder hin ziehen
also wir haben zum beispiel eine
wasserstraße leiden auch er hatte ein
hochwasser an ihrem namen alle ehre
gemacht und ich weiß dass viele von den
bewohnern gesagt haben nein wir suchen
uns eine andere wohnung das ist das
deshalb den ersten gegner aus jedes mal
zu schauen auch die wasserstraße wieder
eine wasserstraße
ja das ist also da stockt einem der atem
wenn sie deutlich machen von 2013 bis
2020 wiederaufbau also das wort sagt
sich so leicht wieder aufbau aber ihre
gemeinde zeigt also das dauert sehr
lange
jetzt haben sie gesagt da habe ich jetzt
auch ein fragezeichen sie sagen
innerhalb von 14 tagen mussten sie
sozusagen ermitteln was der schaden ist
und das an das land melden um die mittel
zu bekommen
aber ich vermute mal dass auch in den 14
tagen man schwierig sagen kann die alles
wird und wir kennen das ja von
straßenbauten von xetra man veranschlagt
3 millionen am ende sind 26 millionen
ist dass am ende aus so gewesen dass die
schäden die sie berechneten am ende aber
die kosten noch viel viel viel größer
geworden sind die kosten sind natürlich
größer geworden aber gott sei dank war
es so dass wir in vielen und vor allem
begründeten fällen nach melden konnten
und diese nachmeldung die sind dann auch
überwiegend akzeptiert worden
aber es ist trotzdem eine wahnsinns
herausforderung gewesen ja alle
ingenieure waren an bord als erfolg
gewertet und das geschickte angesagt das
fast neue straße das kostet neue
abwasserkanal was das neue wasserleitung
und so weiter das war das wilde zeit wo
zwölf-stunden-tag sagenhaften werden
kommen wird jetzt hat herr laschet der
cdu ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen heute gesagt dass
bund bund und land werden das
zusammenstellen er hat aber auch
hinzugefügt aber es wird trotzdem danach
ein anderes land werden in diesen
städten hochwassergefahr werde auch in
zukunft immer wieder bestehen und die
städte müssten daher hochwasser
resilient wieder aufgebaut werden so
laschet heute das deckt sich mit einigen
fragen und kommentaren die wir hier
haben eine ein user schreibt über
youtube dort wieder ein haus aufzubauen
ist doch wie russisch roulette spielen
wie sieht das denn aus mit dem
hochwasserschutz da ist man in
deutschland hinter der schweiz zurück
usw
es gibt also auch mehrere gedanken und
fragen wie ist das denn wiederaufbau
heißt ja nicht nur das haus wieder
aufbauen die straße wieder flicken die
kanalisation wiederherstellen sondern
wiederaufbau heißt ja auch darüber
nachzudenken was macht man wie baut man
jetzt anders damit eben beim nächsten
hochwasser beim nächsten naturereignis
das ganze vermieden wird herr opitz war
das für sie in den jahren von 2013 bis
2020 jetzt auch das thema natürlich
genauso wie man sich gegen häuser gelegt
wo man sozusagen direkt vor anschluss
bringt ob man den unbedingt in keller
oder im erdgeschoss unterbringen muss so
auf mein leben nicht weiter höher nie
genau so raten gästen die
straßenbeleuchtung und wieder andere
energetische dinge anstellt verlegt wo
das erfahren wir daher waren wo eine
höhere sicherheit war
wir haben viele flächen entsiegelt wir
haben kann dann sehr die kanalisation
natürlich steht lassen wir sind nicht
mehr wasser aufnehmen kann
dass wir im stark legen zahl um
einsetzen können wir den kanal er ziehen
und das stadtleben fällen eben erst da
nicht auch dieses effekt dass das wasser
über die straßen in die keller läuft
dass das eintreten kann also all diesen
sieht man dann quasi
durch diese starke regen oder hochwasser
wille und sagt sich um gottes willen wo
kommt denn auch das war es auch her und
wenn man halt in den fall ist dann weiß
man das wasser kommt vom berg und dann
muss man sich möglicherweise überlegen
ob sich das wirklich möglich ist
wasserrückhaltebecken oder gram und so
weiter anzuheben damit eben tatsächlich
plötzliche riesen bus nicht kommt
sondern das ist derzeit verzögert ist
dass diese dinge so gebaut werden dass
die nachhaltig sind und man nicht vor
einem großen so einer großen katastrophe
aber wenn man sie einmal legt dann weiß
man aus wie viele kleinere verlage rufen
die auszeit schäden hinterlassen und
auch man das durch bauliche maßnahmen
beides geht verhindern kann oder
zumindestens sprechen kann
also das war für uns eine ganz wichtige
aufgabe und diese dinge in verantwortung
der gemeinde stand aber auch wir haben
versucht den gebäudeeigentümern ganz
klar zu sagen also ihr müsst versuchen
so zu versichern auf eurem wohnt stück
da ist gar nicht erst auf den
wassermassen zum beispiel von dächern
und euch in die kanalisation gedrückt
werden
dass dadurch noch ausstand läuft
sozusagen das regenwasser über die
zurzeit wieder zurück die bruchstücke
vielen dank sozusagen für diese
schilderung für diese erfahrung das ist
auch ein bisschen eine antwort auf eine
frage hier von safenet beziehungsweise
ein kommentar über youtube mich wundert
dass alle vom aufbau der städte reden
und der infrastruktur aber ich lese
nicht zum thema macht es sinn den
überschwemmungsgebieten wieder zu bauen
sie haben deutlich gemacht es wird nicht
außen vor gelassen dass man schon
darüber nachdenken
baut man noch an der stelle sie haben
auch gesagt einige menschen gehen hin
und sagen nein da will ich nicht mehr
wohnen und die kommune sie als
verantwortliche überlegen ja eben auch
was kann man tun dass sich das nicht
wiederholt wir haben auf jeden fall eine
ganze menge gelernt von ihnen beiden ich
danke ganz herzlich wir haben vor allen
dingen aber auch sehr anschaulich von
ihnen geschildert bekommen warum
geldspenden doch
sinnvoller sind zu flexibler einsetzbar
sind sie kommen an wie sie auch verteilt
werden haben wir gelernt und wenn sie
lieber zuschauen und zuschauer heute
sagen jawohl das finde ich richtig da
will ich auch helfen dann können sie das
tun hier wollen wir das noch mal sagen
die möglichkeit über das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe können sie geld
spenden die iban nummer ist de 65 104
106 100 104 106 100 stichwort zdf
hochwasser also wir haben jetzt ein
bisschen gelernt wie es verteilt wird
wie viel schon zusammen gekommen ist und
wie man eben auch sicher sein kann dass
wirklich eigentlich alles getan wird
dass kein schindluder getrieben wird das
wirklich zu den leuten kommt auf der
einen seite die schnelle hilfe die sie
erklärt haben aber auch die langfristige
nachhaltige dann sagen wir ein großes
dankeschön wünschen weiterhin alles gute
drücken ihnen die daumen dass in
heidenau nicht noch mal irgendwann eine
flut kommt wo sie jetzt so viele jahre
gebraucht haben die rechnungen
abzuschließen und drücken also die
daumen dass das was sie auch beschrieben
haben was man vorkehrungen getroffen hat
sich als sinnvoll und richtig erwiesen
hat vielen vielen dank herr opitz grüße
nach sachsen
genauso an alle kollegen und kolleginnen
bürgermeister an die schwere zeit
durchleben sind jetzt bei ihnen und ich
wünsche ihnen viel kraft und zuversicht
und manchmal auch manchmal bin häufig
seien die sorgen der menschen zu
erfassen aber auch manchmal mit einer
entsprechenden hatte damit man das
selber auch verstehen und übersteht
das sind sehr schöne brauchte zum
abschluss und zeigt einfach noch mal was
wir eingehen das gesagt haben wenn man
die solidarität die hilfsbereitschaft
ist schon sehr groß und wenn es auch in
dieser form ist die wird auch nicht ab
man glaube ich ich kann doch raffination
sagen die werden da bleiben solange sie
gebraucht werden jetzt beispielsweise in
der ortschaft grafschaft im kreis
ahrweiler hat ist eine der küche
aufgebaut wurde die 10.000 mahlzeit am
tag kocht und verteilen wird mit 10.000
lunchpaketen 140000 trinkwasser antrag
und die präsidentengarde hat gehört mir
bleiben so lange fort
wie wir gebraucht werden das gilt für
alle anderen auch egal welcher nation
sie gehören die helfer werten nicht
einfach abziehen da können die
betroffenen sich sicher sein und dann
werden alles tun um schnellstmöglich ein
normales leben mehr führen
dann sehen wir ohne mampf auch keinen
wiederaufbau so fern vielen vielen dank
für die information für die schilderung
für ihre erfahrungen ganz ganz
herzlichen dank und an sie liebe
userinnen und user auch liebe zuschauer
und zuschauer auch ein großes dankeschön
für ihr interesse für ihre fragen ich
denke und hoffe wir haben sie
ausführlich und richtig beantwortet dann
sage ich danke schön und einen schönen
abend auch tschüss und auf wiedersehen